una nueva víctima que se suma a una
larga lista poseen farixa de es el
quinto científico nuclear iraní
asesinado en 10 años todos han muerto en
ataques similares tiroteos o coches
bomba
a veces
el renombrado físico masud ali mohammadi
profesor de la universidad de teherán
muere en la explosión de una motocicleta
bomba frente a su casa 11 meses después
majid shahriari un actor clave en el
programa nuclear muere en un ataque
bomba
mahmud ahmadineyad entonces presidente
iraní acusa a israel ya los gobiernos
occidentales de estar detrás de estos
ataques
washington y tel aviv niegan su
participación 2 asesinatos más tuvieron
lugar en los años siguientes así como
intentos fallidos hasta el acuerdo
nuclear iraní de 2015 en 2018 el año en
que donald trump anunció la retirada de
eeuu del acuerdo nuclear los servicios
de inteligencia israelíes confiscan
miles de documentos secretos sobre el
desarrollo nuclear iraní para el primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu esto es una
prueba de que irán busca adquirir armas
nucleares dice que muchos en fariza de
es el cerebro de este plan y una parte
clave del plan era formar nuevas
organizaciones para continuar el trabajo
así lo expresó el doctor
fariza de jefe del proyecto iraní amada
recuerden ese nombre farixa de el
asesinato podría exacerbar las tensiones
regionales en un momento en que eeuu se
encuentra en plena transición
presidencial
donald trump sigue siendo el jefe del
ejército estadounidense hasta el 20 de
enero según el diario the new york times
a principios de este mes
trump consideró atacar un centro nuclear
iraní